the darkness over gaza city flashed
bright by explosions as israeli
artillery and other weapons targeted
what they said were weapons factories
and rocket launch sites belonging to
islamic jihad
moments before an aerial duel as
metaphor rockets were fired from gaza
towards israel with most intercepted by
the israeli iron dome
anti-missile system
islamic jihad said they fired more than
100 rockets
in a televised address the israeli prime
minister yair lapid said his country had
zero tolerance for attacks from gaza but
that israel had no interest in a wider
battle
earlier the israeli defense ministry had
approved the call-up of as many as 25
000 army reservists and raided combat
battalions sparking fears that an
israeli ground invasion was imminent the
daylight attacks were spread throughout
gaza city
one main target was this apartment
building where a senior commander from
islamic jihad taisir al-jabari was
killed
israeli army footage showed what they
said was a suspected rocket launch site
in ghanas
among the dozens of injured and dead the
body of a five-year-old girl was carried
throughout the streets
what is this child's fault she was
dreaming of going to kindergarten and
asked her father for a school bag and
clothes what has she done wrong this
innocent child
other funeral processions were escorted
by running crowds fearful of the next
attack
one gaza resident described what she
heard and
uh i heard about four to five
loud bangs i was asleep and i just found
myself waking up running wondering what
happened and people in the in the
building they just run down to the
street you know because they fear that
there's gonna be other apartments
targeted
islamic jihad said israel had made a
declaration of war and promised to fight
back
this is a declaration of all-out war
against the palestinian people we will
respond to that this is a violation and
disregard for all the efforts that have
been made over the past days in order to
restore calm we dealt positively with
these efforts but the enemy was as usual
treacherous
the israeli action followed the closure
of two border crossings with the gaza
strip earlier in the week and the arrest
of senior islamic jihad members in the
occupied west bank
and the office of the palestinian
president mahmoud abbas called friday's
attack a dangerous escalation
the yuan cautioned against further
civilian casualties while egyptian
mediators are trying to diffuse the
tension between both sides but this
escalation is something that we have
seen time and time again here in gaza
and the heaviest price is always paid by
the people yumna seed al jazeera gaza
city
john holman has more from the sikkim
junction on the israel gada bullseye
so far at the moment uh we're more than
160 rockets um fired from gaza towards
um
israel
what is the israeli military is saying
is that very few of those have hit any
points uh um of importance that the ones
that haven't been deflected and stopped
by iron dome which is israelis
anti-rocket system uh have landed
instead either within gaza or in
depopulated
areas so there's no serious injuries
reported so far by those rockets
in gaza where they obviously don't have
those same systems and where it's being
um hit hard by the israeli strikes so
the latest on this side is israeli media
is reporting that the defense minister
uh uh benny gantz uh is
saying that this will continue that
they're not at the point of stopping yet
the israeli line on this is that they're
going after islamic jihad targets within
gaza they're also looking to hit things
like weapon storage and rocket launchers
they say that they've just hit and gone
after
a rocket launcher
and that's what's been happening
throughout the night so saying that
they're not letting islamic jihad set
the agenda here
israeli forces say they've arrested 19
members of islamic jihad in the occupied
west bank now troops raided sites in the
city of janine and in the calandria area
south of ramallah
the united nations middle east
coordinator has called for a
de-escalation of the fighting kristen
salumi has more from un headquarters
there can be no justification for
attacks on civilians those are the words
of middle east coordinator tor venisland
in response to the recent attacks in
gaza he noted that a five-year-old child
is among the dead and expressed concern
that this escalation between
palestinian militants and israel
and what he described as the targeted
killing of the palestinian islamic jihad
leader
could further exacerbate tensions in the
region tensions which have been
growing and brewing not only in gaza but
also across the west bank and of course
it's the united nations that gets called
in to pick up the pieces after conflicts
like this in the occupied territories
and he expressed concern that civilians
will ultimately be the ones who pay the
worst price at a time when international
support and international funding to
help in situations like this is
stretched very thin so a word of caution
from the middle east coordinator
words released on twitter and in
statements to the media calling on both
sides to tone down their response and
protect civilians